gavin is with us in houston texas hi
gavin how are you
good how are y'all doing better than we
deserve how can we help
so i'm 25 and due to a very fortunate
situation
i kind of got doubly lucky here and got
some money from my parents and my
grandfather
and also got really lucky investing in
some things i didn't completely
understand with that money like you
like you often say uh the tricky part
about that now is that 95
of my net worth is in stocks and i only
make 50 grand a year
um getting ready to buy a house with my
fiance i'm just concerned about the
capital gains tax hit to create a down
payment for the house so i'm thinking
i've made my fair share of dumb
decisions with this money being young
obviously i've got a big chevy tahoe
that you know
i don't think i necessarily deserve but
i just happen to like so i'm thinking do
i sell it to
number one be debt free and create
positive equity to maybe absorb that
taxes or do i keep the truck just
because i enjoy it
is the truck paid for yeah it's got 28
000 left
on it but um yeah i'm either way i'm not
taking the car payment anymore so i'm
thinking
uh in both situations i'm either writing
it off
you're 25 years old you make 50 000
you have a 28 000 truck and you have how
much in this investment account
about 650 000 wow
wow yeah
you've been blessed beyond measure sir
yes and how much
how much of that is gain that is over a
year old
um probably about 70 of it
okay so that'll be taxed at 15
and it's in single stocks and from the
way you're describing this it sounds
like it's a fairly high risk
situation am i right uh some of it is
the
i decided you know i got scared of it
pretty early so i moved
60 of it into management i would say the
other 40
is individual stocks around consumer
data collection and medical diagnostic
data collection
yeah okay yeah uber high risk cut
cutting edge uh small cap technologies
and yeah you're pretty much playing
russian roulette with those things or
the roulette wheel anyway
um so uh the way
i answer questions we answer questions
on this show is what will we do if we
woke up in your shoes
yeah man yeah first off
thank goodness you're where you are
congratulations it's wonderful
the danger is is that it worked and that
you may try to do it again
that's that that's the dangerous part
it's like the guy that drops one quarter
into a slot machine and wins and he
spends the rest of his vacation putting
all his money in the slot machine trying
to do it again
uh because you're not going to do it
again uh so i
d i do not i do not have investments of
those types
because they scare me and
um and my real estate portfolio alone is
worth hundreds of millions
so i can speak with uh emotional
authority
in this situation how it feels uh when i
was your age i was a millionaire and i
lost everything
and i don't want you to fall into that
so what i would do
is i would um move anything that is not
in a managed account
in mutual funds into that and i would
pay off the truck tomorrow if you're
going to keep it
normally we say do not own things that
are more than half your annual income
this
is barely but you also have 650 000
freaking dollars laying over here so i
think you can afford to drive this truck
if you want to
right um and then uh
believe it or not i'm gonna suggest you
do not buy a home with your fiance right
now
number one you don't buy homes with
people you're not married to
after you're married i would rent
something
even if it's something nice for six
months
get to know each other yeah it takes
about a year of being married to know
how close to your mother-in-law to buy
yeah yeah
in other words after a year of marriage
you will make a different housing
decision than you would make today
together we've been running here uh for
about
uh two years we've been i mean we'd
probably you're not
married yeah correct after you've been
married a while you will make a
different decision
than you would make as shacked-up
fiancees
uh it's a different thing it just is
that's the truth and so i would take my
time
yeah and you you've been the there's a
tortoise in the hair you've been the
hair
and you're ahead in the race and i'm
going to switch sides and become the
tortoise
and i'm just going to slow your butt
down
on the investing and on the house
i'm really happy with where you are and
you're obviously a very sharp guy yeah
i mean you're obviously very bright so
you may not do anything we say to do
but you called and asked us which the
danger of that is we're going to tell
you tell you the truth and i think he
will dave i
i think he's he's a little nervous he's
a little scared he wants to make the
right decision she wants to buy house
yeah and here's the thing dave i was
going to say instead of her
you know save like you said spend the
first six months to a year once you all
get married
and then with him walking away after he
pays the capital gains i pay cash
i pay cash for the house that's what i
was going to say and i'm saying cash
like a two three hundred thousand dollar
home
400. i don't care yeah 500. you know i
don't care
now you're good really good everything's
paid for everything
the money's gone yeah most of it but
you're totally gone your taxes well i
mean by the time you it's not going it's
not in the sense of it's that
investment accounts yes yes but your
taxes at 15
on 70 of 650
is just that's not going to [ __ ] the
situation tonight
uh and yes i would pay the capital gains
in order to get this in the right
setting yeah and it doesn't sound like
that much of it's gonna be subject to
capital gains because it sounds like
you've already done that when you moved
it from
these higher and higher risk things into
the managed stuff you probably took your
capital gains yet then yeah
because you liquidated the investments
to move them that's my guess anyway
um i don't know exactly how you did that
but that's that's what it sounds like
you did to me
so anyway i'm going to pay what capital
gains you got to pay
for making the move and i'd get it all
under managed and i would sit there rent
something for a little for a year
after marriage or six months after
you're married then i would buy with
cash and
pay off the car today yeah and i want to
say this to america listening
i know you all probably said oh man that
worked for him let me go try that
no do not do it i mean i think the
numbers dave i don't know the updated
numbers but it's right around 78
of the people who play in this field do
not make a dime they actually
lose money and so um
yes you hear it worked over here uh but
it does not mean
more than likely it will not work if you
had a buddy that had a hit or lottery
ticket doesn't mean that it's smart to
buy lottery tickets yes
it's just you know that's the bottom
line yeah and so
and brandon's are gavin's smart enough
to
wise enough to be a little bit afraid in
this situation
but congratulations that you're there
yeah i'm so happy
that you're 25 years old and you have
650 000 that's just so cool yeah
i'm just that's so neat and thanks for
calling in and asking the question yeah
so you get to do what you want to do
you're grown up that's what we would
tell you to do
yes thanks for calling